it's power that comes on to the ice Johnson goes
to the bench after that pass and the sabes work
their way into the Ottawa Zone here's garon's
in tight and that one stopped by forsberg well
get the puck down low winning battles taken
to the net and this is going to be an example
KBS just throws this one back down oh good shot
by cousins keeping it low but the guys in front
of the net here have to find that they got to
know that's coming and get themselves ready
if it comes off hot like that strong entry
for a power comes into AC cross scores JJ
PKA they came with speed they came in hot and
the Sabers take a one- nothing lead good job
here by the Savers as this penalty just is over
but Power lugging this Puck up the ice get it
and look he just he continues going there what it
does it backs off everybody for Ottawa if he had
to just put on the brakes there everybody's in
good position but he takes a few extra strides
he keeps going before he peels off but what
a move right there by Dylan cousins stepping
past his man regaining control of the pock off
the face off of the Buffalo Zone McKuen comes up
with it for Ottawa slaps it around the boards
it'll be kept in as Shabbat brings it down to
the bottom of the circle trying to Center teras
senko up top scores lot of traffic in front that
time luk and I'm not sure if he saw that one
at all now I think it goes straight in terce
ankko from the point here and this is tereno
on the point here's the quick shot and he's
out there battling he's looking he's thinking he
had it and we'll see exactly where it goes boom
just catches short side right there so did
he make contact with Lucan in at all if so
where yeah your last game didn't leave a good
taste in your mouth for sure but the Savers
won three the last five games they need to stay
on that pace for the rest of the year far close
chance here by kylo B let's take a look here this
is Benson stepping over From The Far Side trying
to wrap around there and I love how the young man
just wants to take this Puck to the net all the
time aall playing with 7D here tonight so you'll
see a couple of different looks from time to time
Sabers quick get it up for Benson onehanded shot
goes just wide and then onehanded yeah one-handed
here doing his job to still the rush but tereno
let that one RI and off the blocker that time of
Luc Sabers come to Center
Ice Tas Thompson carries it
scores Tage Thompson shot that puck with an
attitude and it listened as it hums to the
back of the net and the Sabers take a two to
one lead that he's comfortable shooting in and
he's going to let it go there's no extra moves
there's no extra plays he's going to get the pot
to the net here once again gets him raid in the
middle the ice there just above the hash marks
right at the top of the circles and he lets
it rip and he looks around he knows there's
nobody with him you see him take a quick look
there's nobody there with him he's by himself
he's got to take the shot Bine will send it down
low this time as auttaa aggressive on the puck
behind the net back up top for dolene takes a
look cage Thompson over at the left Circle 29
seconds to go SC backto back darts by T andt
and Tage Thompson has given Buffalo a 3 to
one lead with the power play goal excited
as well because they know if they get the
big man rolling a lot of things are going
to fall into place behind it here nice job
just on the wall he's got the time and space
and he's comfortable shooting from that area
and he's going to take the shot watch you got
middle stat and you got Tuck they're in front
of the net rebound goes to the front middle
stats got it stopped on the short side tuck
there Ryan Johnson out of the box now here's K
two on one kuss passes across gets it back scor
Payton CR gives the Savers a 4 to one lead with
1508 to go in Period number two it's a nice one
but it's all because of the pressure once again
here's Krebs slides it across and he's going to
get it back again and when he gets it back because
it was a perfect pass by Eric Robinson right back
to him Corpus Sal has zero chance on this one but
you just see the pressure the Sabers are putting
on the Ottawa centers all over the I and that
up the middle just misses kachuck Buffalo able
to play it ahead but Dylan cousins can't move
it up Ridley Greg to the slot puts one off the
bar relaxed and stuff like this is going to happen
there's the quick shot goes right off the crossbar
and a bit of a bowling alley of players down this
right side and Ottawa Force back to their own Zone
here's bson with a shot sto by Lucan this is him
right here and he has to go he's on his offside
there and Ja Maran standing on the bench there you
just that look he's giving a lot of the times when
guys are coming off the ice I know that look not
real happy myself and Daniel Alon got a lot of
things to try to figure out here drop p kachuck
for Ridley CG in front pck stays with a backand
scores Jus stayed with it in front of the net
and the Senators cut the lead in half it is 4-2
Buffalo with an early goal here by Ottawa in the
first minute of the game and just kind of drive
by there's the first block made then the puck
is turned over by Jack Quinn right in front of
the net and that's what led to the opportunity Z
just stepped into it power's got him he's there
so when Jack Quinn gets that Pock and he turns
you see Eric Johnson he's stung a little bit
he's down on the ice H he's not there to GL down
by the Sabers Casey middle stat ahead to Tage
Thompson two back of the first Tommy dangles to
the net and the rebound is saved by Corpus Salo
around the defender right there they're just
looking for the shot trying to block it gets
him caught flat footed just across the line stop
by shabat susler comes back the other way into
the Buffalo Zone turns it inside two on one down
low big save by Lucan and the puck drifts over to
the far side and now back behind the net up the
near wall for garson's not out shot well wide
to the goal chicken will keep it in at the Far
Point the Chuck Tred to Center and lcan it again
with a stop moving his feet and racing down the
left side here's crab strikes a shot Rebound in
front and it's still free Eric Robinson had a
stab at it but for brano made the stop up top
looking for Bernard Docker comes outside the line
and the cmore the native just outside of Calgary
will Retreat and send it right back up into the
Buffalo Zone they stay on side Puck scorts to the
front of the net but Dylan cousins is there can't
move it up scores shot from the far Circle by
giru and he's got his second's got his 12th of
the Year here and so right here just got plenty
of opportunity to get rid of that Pock or getting
into a safe area and right there as cousins getss
this Puck he's checked from behind right there
is stick to stick from tchuk and it goes right
to zeru and jaru just jumps onto this one it looks
like it's right on the ice 339 on his career goal
total now at 341 Savers look to the counter and
Corpus Salo trying to play Savior for Ottawa
racing after it is Sanderson power intercepts he
lifts one down the ice to The Emptiness oh it's
off the PO post inside of the post and across
the blue paint hauled down as he tried to make
a play on the puck and then it's turned over and
Dylan cousins he's got an empty n Dylan cousins
scores the Workhorse from White Horse with
the empty net goal with 2.1 seconds to go in
the third Buffalo five Auto off three really
good defensive job here a look at this one
Greenway getting down blocking that shot but
getting back up and being able to play it and
then once again the pressure the Sabers able to
put on the top side there for the Auto Centers
they end up turning up the pock and and the
Sabres will have four wins in their last six
games and they reached the 40o mark and maybe here
we go but right now you celebrate
the 5-3 win over the Rival senator